conference i want to begin
by thanking you for editing at the
election
pounding the streets in the middle of
winter prodding leaflets
through the letterbox and into the jaws
of dogs to save this country from
socialism
and to win this party the biggest
election victory
in a generation i was going to say how
great it is
to be here in birmingham but the fact is
they were not in birmingham this is not
a conference hall and alas i can't see
any of you in front of me there's no one
to clap or heckle i don't know about you
but i have had more than enough
of this disease that attacks not only
human beings
but so many of the greatest things about
our country
our pubs our clubs our football our
theater
and all the gossipy gregariousness and
love of human contact that drives the
creativity of our economy
and so i want to thank you all for
zooming in
and i can tell you that your government
is working night and day
to repel this virus and we will
succeed just as this country has seen
off
every alien invader for the last
thousand years
and we will succeed by collective
effort by following the guidance and
with the help
of weekly and almost daily improvements
in the medicine
and the science we will ensure the next
time we meet
it will be face to face and cheek
by jiao and we're working for the day
when life will be back to normal flying
in a plane
will be back to normal and hairdressers
will no longer look as though they're
handling radioactive isotopes and when
we can
go and see our loved ones in care homes
and when we no longer have to greet each
other by touching
elbows as in some giant national version
of the birdie dance
i know the people of this country are
going to defeat this virus
because i've seen how the country's
responded before
with the energy and self-sacrifice of
the nhs the care workers
the armed services the spirit that was
incarnated in the binding boundless
devotion
of captain tom moore
but after all we've been through
it isn't enough just to go back to
normal
we've lost too much we've mourned
too many we've been through too much
frustration
and hardship just to settle for the
status quo anti
to think that life can go on as it was
before
the plague and it will not because
history teaches us that events
of this magnitude wars famines plagues
events that affect the vast bulk of
humanity as this virus has
they don't just come and go
they are more often than not the trigger
for an acceleration of social and
economic change because we human beings
will
simply not content ourselves with a
repair job
we see these moments as the time to
learn
and to improve on the world that went
before and that's why
this government will build back better
and to explain what i mean by build back
better
i'll use a medical metaphor
i've read a lot of nonsense recently
about how my
own bout of kovid has somehow robbed me
of my mojo and of course this is
self-evident drivel
the kind of seditious propaganda that
you'd expect from people who don't want
this government
to succeed who wanted to stop us
delivering brexit and all our other
manifesto pledges and i could tell you
that no power on earth was
and is going to do that and i could
refute
these critics of my athletic abilities
in any way they want
arm wrestling leg wrestling couple and
wrestling sprint off
you name it and yet i have to admit
the reason i had such a nasty experience
with the disease is that
although i was superficially in the pink
of health when i caught it i had a very
common underlying
condition my friends i was too fat
and i've since lost 26 pounds and you
can imagine that in
bags of sugar and i'm going to continue
that diet because you've got to
search for the hero inside yourself in
the hope that individual is considerably
slimmer and when you look
at the general economic condition of the
country
when we went into lockdown there was a
an analogy a similarity because we were
on the face of it
in pretty good shape we had a record
number of people
in jobs we had record low unemployment
we were seeing growing exports and
of course the only reason as rishi sunak
has pointed out that in the last
few months we've been able to cope with
the cost of the pandemic
to look after jobs and livelihoods in
the way that we have
is that in previous years we had
sensible
conservative management of public
finances
and yet if you looked more carefully
you could see and indeed many of us said
so at the time
that the uk economy had some chronic
underlying problems long-term failure
to tackle the deficit in skills
inadequate transport
infrastructure not enough homes people
could afford to buy
especially young people and far too many
people across the whole country
who felt ignored and left out that the
government was not on their side
and so we can't now define the mission
of this country
as merely to restore normality
that isn't good enough in the depths of
the second world war when just about
everything had gone wrong the government
sketched out
a vision of the post-war
new jerusalem that they wanted to build
and that's what we're doing now in the
teeth
of this pandemic we're resolving not to
go back to 2019 but to do
better to reform our system of
government to renew
our infrastructure to spread opportunity
more widely
and fairly and create the conditions for
a dynamic recovery that is led
not by the state but by free enterprise
we need to move fast not just to deal
with the immediate economic fallout
but because after 12 years of relative
anemia we need to lift the trend rate of
growth
we need to lift people's incomes not
just
go back to where we were and it's clear
from
covid that we need the economic
robustness
to deal with whatever the next cosmic
spanner
may be hurtling towards us in the dark
and the only way to ensure true
resilience
and long-term prosperity is to raise the
overall productivity
of the country and the bedrock
of national productivity is of course
something that we are
responsible for having great public
services
on which everyone families businesses
investors can rely
that means first a great health service
and so it's right this government is
pressing on with its plan for 48
hospitals
count them that's eight already underway
and then 40 more between
now and 2030 we need to get on
with recruiting the 50 000 more nurses
and i'm proud that we have 14 000 more
since this government came into office
14
000 more nurses now under this
conservative government
in the last year and yet that isn't
enough
we've seen the frantic global scrabble
for vaccines for therapies
and so now we're doubling our funding
for all types of revolutionary
scientific
breakthroughs with a national advanced
research and
project agency and while we're at it
we'll do what all governments have
shirked
for decades we will fix the injustice
of care home funding bringing the magic
of averages
to the rescue of millions
covid has shown a spotlight on the
difficulties of that sector
in all parts of the uk and to build back
better
we must respond care
for the carers as they care for us
and if we're to raise productivity and
encourage investment in the uk then
there is one thing
we must do as a matter of basic
hygiene and that is to fight crime and
so yes
we are fulfilling our manifesto
commitment to put another 20 000
officers out on the street and i'm prior
that we've already recruited
almost 5 000 but fan though i am of the
police we need to see results not just
spending
so we're also backing those police up
protecting the public
by changing the law to stop the early
release of serious
sexual and violent offenders and
stopping the whole criminal justice
system from being hamstrung by what the
home secretary would doubtless
and rightly call the lefty human rights
lawyers and other
do-gooders and in spite of the pandemic
the home secretary and i are having
regular comp stat style sessions
with the chief constables when we look
at the crime data across the country
and compare performance and work out
what we
can do to help town by town
we're rooting out the county lines drugs
gangs that are causing so much misery
and in that sense our agenda
is basic social justice when i talk
about leveling up
i mean making the streets safer for
everyone and when i talk about leveling
up
i mean not just investing massively in
our schools delivering
on our promise to raise per-pupil
funding to 4 000 pounds per head in
primary school
and 5 000 pounds per head in secondary
school as well as a
30 000 starting salary for teachers i'm
thinking not just
about the inputs but about the outputs
the changes
in the lives of young people and so i
want to take
further an idea that we've tried in the
pandemic
and to explore the value of one-to-one
teaching both for pupils who are in
danger of falling behind
and for those of exceptional abilities
we can all see
the difficulties but i believe such
intensive teaching could be
transformational out of massive
reassurance to parents
it's in crises like this that new
approaches
are born and last week we grasped
a nettle that has intimidated
governments for the last century
we effectively broke down the senseless
barrier
between further education and higher
education
so that it's just as easy to get the
funding you need
for a training course in engineering or
i.t
as for a degree in politics or economics
because we're offering every adult
four years of funded post 18
education a lifetime skills
guarantee a lifetime skills guarantee
from internet shopping to working from
home
it looks as though kovid has massively
accelerated
changes in the world of work and as old
jobs are lost
and new jobs are created we're offering
free training
for adults without a levels in vital
skills from adult care
to wind turbine maintenance and
the kovid crisis is a catalyst for
change
so we need to give people the chance to
train for the new jobs that are being
created every day and there's one area
where we are progressing with gale force
speed and that is the green economy
the green industrial revolution that in
the next 10 years
will create hundreds of thousands if not
millions
of jobs i can today announce that the uk
government
has decided to become the world leader
in low-cost clean
power generation cheaper than coal
cheaper than gas
and we believe that in ten years time
offshore wind
will be powering every home in the
country with our target rising from 30
gigawatts
to 40 gigawatts you heard me right your
kettle
your washing machine your cooker your
heating your plug-in electric vehicle
the whole lot of them
will get their juice cleanly and without
guilt
from the breezes that blow around these
islands
we will invest 160 million pounds in
ports and factories
across the country to manufacture the
next generation of turbines and
we'll not only build fixed arrays in the
sea we will build
windmills that float on the sea enough
to deliver
one gigawatt of energy by 2030. that's
15 times floating windmills 15 times
as much as the rest of the world put
together
far out in the deepest waters we will
harvest the gusts
and by upgrading infrastructure in such
places as
t-side and humber and scotland and wales
we will increase an offshore wind
capacity
that is already the biggest in the world
as saudi arabia is to oil the uk
is to wind a place of almost limitless
resource but in the case of wind without
the carbon emissions without the damage
to the environment
i remember how some people used to sneer
at wind power
20 years ago and say it wouldn't pull
the skin off a rice pudding
well they forgot the history of this
country
it was offshore wind that puffed the
sails of drake and rally
and nelson and propelled this country to
commercial greatness
this investment in offshore wind alone
will help to create sixty thousand
jobs in this country and help us to get
to net zero carbon emissions by twenty
fifty
imagine that future with high skilled
green collar jobs in wind in solar in
nuclear
hydrogen and in carbon capture and
storage
retrofitting herbs ground source heat
pumps
mother nature has savaged us
with covid but with the help of basic
natural phenomena we will build back and
bounce back
greener and this government will lead
that green
industrial revolution we will create the
conditions
for individuals and for companies to
flourish with a
high skill low crime economy and
if there was a physical audience in
front of me now i would solicit cheers
by shouting out the details of our
revolution in transport infrastructure
the a-roads we're going to upgrade the
rail lines we're building
or electrifying the simple ways in which
we will improve your lives your daily
commute but we must be clear
that there comes a moment when the state
must stand back and let the private
sector
get on with it i have a simple message
for
all those on the left the labour party
who think everything can be funded by
uncle sugar uh the taxpayer
it isn't the state that produces the new
drugs and the therapies
we're now using it isn't the state that
will hold the intellectual property of
the vaccine if and when
we get one it wasn't the state that made
the gloves and the masks and the
ventilators
that we needed at such speed
it was the private sector with its
rational
interest in innovation and competition
and market share and
yes sales we must not
draw the wrong economic conclusion
from this crisis rishi sunak the
chancellor has come up with some
brilliant expedience to help business to
protect jobs
and livelihoods but let's face it he has
done
things that no conservative chancellor
would have wanted to do except in times
of war
or disaster this government has been
forced by the pandemic into erosions
of liberty that we deeply regret
and to an expansion in the role of the
state from lockdown enforcement to the
many bailouts and
and subsidies that go against our
instincts
but we accept them because there is
simply no reasonable
alternative and yet on the left in the
labour party
there are many who regard this state
expansion as
progress and who want to keep the state
supporting furlough forever keep people
in suspended animation and to want to
keep the state
preempting and spending almost half
our national income we conservatives
believe that way lies disaster
and that we must build back better by
becoming
more competitive both in tax and in
regulation
we need to make this the best place to
start a business the best place to
invest
and we need to unleash the urge not just
to build
but to own we need
to fix our broken housing market
when kovid struck there were millions of
people often young people
who found themselves locked down in
rented accommodation
without private space without a garden
forced to use ironing boards for desks
and bedrooms for offices
and i know that there are many people
who of course very happy with renting
the flexibility
that it offers but for most people it is
still true
that the overwhelming instinct is to buy
and many of them simply can't not
because they can't afford
the mortgage but because they can't
afford the deposit
and the disgraceful truth is that levels
of owner occupation
for the under 40s have plummeted in this
country
and millions of people are forced to pay
through the nose to rent
a home they can't truly love or make
their own
because they can't add a knob or a
knocker to the front door and in some
cases they can't even hang
a picture let alone pass it on to their
children
yes we will transform the sclerotic
planning system we will make it faster
and easier to build
beautiful new homes without destroying
the green belt or desecrating
our countryside but these reforms will
take time and
they're not enough on their own we need
now to take forward one of the key
proposals
of our manifesto of 2019
giving young first-time buyers the
chance to take out a long-term
fixed-rate mortgage of up to 95
of the value of the home vastly reducing
the size of the deposit and giving the
chance of home ownership and all the
joy and the pride that goes with it to
millions
who currently feel excluded we believe
that this policy
could create two million more owner
occupiers
the biggest expansion of home ownership
since the 1980s
we will help turn generation rent
into generation by we will fix the
long-term problems of this country not
by endlessly expanding
the state but by giving power back
to people the fundamental life-affirming
power of home ownership
the power to decide what color to paint
your own front door
with our long-term fixed-rate mortgages
we want to spread that opportunity
to every part of the country and
that is the difference between us
conservatives and the labour opposition
they may have million pound homes in
north london but they deeply dislike
home ownership for anyone else we want
to level up they want to level down
we're proud of this country's culture
and history and traditions
they literally want to pull statues down
to rewrite the history of our country
to edit our national cv to make it look
more politically correct
we aren't embarrassed to sing old songs
about how
britannia rules the waves in fact we're
even making sense of it
with a concerted national shipbuilding
strategy that will bring jobs
to every part of the uk especially in
scotland and we believe
passionately in our wonderful union
our united kingdom while the labour
opposition have done frankly nothing to
defend the union
and continue to flirt with those who
would tear
our country apart and i say frankly to
those
separatist scottish nationalists who
would like this
country to be distracted and divided
by yet more constitutional wrangling now
is the time
to pull together and build back better
in every part
of the united kingdom we believe
in global britain as a proud independent
and outward looking country
and next year we will lead the world at
the g7 and the cop 26 summit in glasgow
with three great campaigns to bring the
world
together to heal the world tackling the
virus tackling
climate change and championing global
free trade
we have confidence in our values and our
diplomacy
and be in no doubt that they are
secretly scheming to overturn brexit and
take us back
into the eu we believe in our fantastic
armed services as one of the greatest
exports that this country has
they the labour party can't even vote
for measures
to protect veterans from vexatious
prosecutions
50 years later when no new evidence
is supplied and throughout this pandemic
it is this government that has taken the
tough decisions
because we believe that there are no
easy answers
while they've simply sniped from the
sidelines well
my friends we have no time now to focus
on captain hindsight
and his regiment of pot shots snipe shot
fusiliers i want you to raise your eyes
and i want you to imagine that you're
arriving in britain
in 2030 well i hope that much of the
program
that i have outlined will be delivered
and you arrive in your
zero carbon jet made in the uk and you
flash your brexit blue passport or your
digital
id you get an ev electric vehicle taxi
and as you travel around
you see a country that has been and is
being
transformed for the better where young
people in their 20s and 30s have the
joy of home ownership and where they can
bring up children in the neighborhoods
where they grow up themselves
in the confidence that the schools are
excellent and the crime
is down and instead of being dragged on
big commutes
to the city they can start a business in
their home town a place
that has not only superb transport
connections and green buses
but gigabit broadband and where the
workforce is
abundantly equipped not just with
university degrees
but with the technical skills that the
new economy
demands and among other landmarks you
will see
48 new hospitals and a population that
is healthier
and happier and quite a bit thinner from
a better diet and
taking so much exercise in the new cycle
lanes
and walking among the millions of trees
that have been planted and going for
picnics
in the new wild belts that now mark the
landscape
you'll notice that the air is cleaner
because most people are now drying evs
while some of the trucks
are actually running on hydrogen even
some of the trains
and i believe you will see a britain
that is more united
than for decades in its constitutional
settlement
where brexit has delivered a new
excitement and verve
not just free trade and free ports but
control over our fisheries
and the ability to do things differently
and better
from innovation in tech and data and
finance to improving
our standards in animal welfare
yes you'll see a country that
scrupulously controls
its own borders but which is in some
ways more
cosmopolitan than ever before welcoming
scientists and artists and people of
talent
from around the world a britain that is
proud of our culture
and history and unashamed of our
heritage
but also unblinkered about the present
embracing every person with love and
respect
whatever their race or creed or gender
or orientation
that is the britain we can build
in its way and with all due respect
to everywhere else the greatest place on
earth
indeed that is the country in the
society
that we are in the process of building
and i know that it seems tough now
when we're tackling the indignities and
cruelty
and absurdity of the disease
but i believe it's a measure of the
greatness of this country
that we are simply not going to let it
hold us back or slow us down
and we're certainly not going to let it
get us down
not for a moment because even in the
darkest moments
we can see the bright future ahead
and we can see how to build it and we're
going to build it
together thank you all very much